hello everybody markiplier here it is
finally time the contest has officially
drawn to a close I dropped the last name
in the bucket just a little bit ago and
this is my upgraded bucket from what I
have over here before this is my buckets
final form it is jam-packed with 1897
shares and it was a pain in the ass to
write them all down some of you have the
longest usernames in the world but it
doesn't matter because this whole
promotion thing has been incredibly
successful to the channel but I want to
like point out that I didn't do this
specifically so that we could grow the
channel it was just an idea that I had
because I did want to give back with the
Borderlands 2 with a free game giveaway
and all that I'm just mixing up mixing
up the names here there's like literally
like just a handful is just that many
names and there's still that much left
in the bucket so there's a lot in here
and they're pretty jam-packed but anyway
I really emphasize that this lake wasn't
really about just building the channel
was really about giving something back
to you guys so I hope that you had fun
with it telling your friends about me
tying them to chairs binding and gagging
them and forcing them and watch my
videos which was the requirement the
original requirement I don't know if not
many of you follow the rules but yeah
the original crime was to tie him down
most likely do a bed or something keep
their eyes open and make him watch it
but you know I did what I could you know
I worked with what I had so some of you
went out there so that's great
alright so the top sharer which I'll
start out with with 156 years and this
was incredible because um this guy sent
out like not just Facebook and Twitter
and not just tumblr you did you did
those and then he did he found all these
little gaming forums on me and he sent
mail and World of Warcraft and all that
stuff so the winner for the most shares
and there were some they'll say they had
more some of it was just spammy so I
kind of I I did some internal editing so
but there's still some that are pretty
high up there anyway the winner of the
most shares the top shares with 156
was intrepid Acrobat int r e PID
underscore ACR zero dat intrepid acrobat
so thank you so much for doing so much
to help the channel it's like it's
really just been incredible what's been
going on recently as you can see the
channel is just exploding and I couldn't
be more thankful to you guys because at
the end of the day that's what it's
about it's it's about you guys helping
me out this was just something that I
wanted to be able to get names in a
bucket to give you guys back okay but
anyway there's been enough stalling
you're all like ah the game you stupid
okay here we go so we're gonna draw
three names if there's a duplicate name
I'll I'll check it out and I'll pick
another name um but all right off
stalling you've heard enough I'm gonna
pick three names blah blah blah
I'll get in contact good so you know I
ain't fibbin I don't want anyone to
think that this isn't legitimate I
really have no stake in who plays or who
wins I just you know want to give away
so and that's about a hundred and fifty
names I don't know I I need to go back
and count they it's hard because I get
duplicate emails from the same people
and new emails every day so it's hard to
get the exact number down alright here
we go not looking who's gonna be the big
winner Oh
Satchmo play Satchmo play
come on focusing on that come on camera
Satchmo play there it is Satchmo play is
the first name I drew out so
congratulations thank you for sharing
that's one down there's two other to go
mixing it up mixing it up real good you
should not spill out okay okay all right
dig real deep down there
okay we got what do we got
what do we get who's this who is you
holy crap it's Hill Beth Jay I know who
I owe you
it's Hill that's Jay holy crap
congratulations Oh oh cool
congratulations Hill Beth Jay I know you
shared a lot so thank you very much your
name was in there quite a bit but no
living there's lots of lots of different
names you could probably see there I'm
really just because I happen to know
this person does not mean that I fibbed
that is he'll Beth Jake so
congratulations he'll birthday and you
can see like everyone's got a different
name in there okay anyway there's one
more draw there's one more draw ready to
go okay digging real deep right again
not looking mixing up real good
let's get another name out of here Oh
Anne Hill best days in my real life
friend or anything I just know her
because she's a she's a pretty loyal fan
she's been around for a while here we go
digging again we got really get in there
really mix it up real good okay here we
go Oh what's this I got a name deer
Luck's duckling deluxe duckling thank
you so much for sharing Deluxe duckling
and congratulations on winning okay if I
called your name I think it's either
deluxe duckling or deluxe chuckling I
think it's deluxe duckling anyway if I
called your name send me an email with
the same email you sent me before and I
will try to get in contact with you also
if I can't get in contact with these
people um please bear with me because
I'll just I'll draw another name I'm not
gonna throw this away I think I'm just
gonna keep this in here so I'll put that
over there I got my bucket that once
again it was deluxe duckling deluxe
duckling he'll Beth Jay and Satchmo play
anyway congratulations you three you
three are gonna win a copy of
Borderlands 2 and if you want you can do
a let's play with me I hope you're up to
it Satchmo play sounds like you're a
youtuber yourself so if you are have a
good microphone that's good deluxe
chuckling I know he'll Beth Jo probably
up for it
deluxe duckling I really hope that
you're up for playing Borderlands 2 so
get in contact with me I'll try to get
in contact with you on the intrepid
Acrobat same deal send me an email on
the same email that you sent me before
and I'll find you I'll send you an I'll
spend you all a message in the in the
future but thank you everybody again I
can't reiterate enough that I just I
love you guys I love getting up in the
morning to entertain you guys it's the
greatest feeling in the world to jump
out of bed and just do stuff like this
for you guys do silly videos like goofy
goober I'm a goofy kid no you know just
doing fun stuff like that especially
with me Wade and Bob um it's just great
feeling be able to get together with my
friends and entertain you guys who are
steadily becoming my internet friends so
it's it's a it's a great feeling and I I
couldn't do without you and I hope to do
it for a long time coming so I I don't
know if I'll do promotions exactly in
this way I might control it a bit more
so doesn't go you know so crazy maybe
like one share per person just so you
know you know it's more even and more
even-handed but it was actually
surprisingly even I think that
statistics were I was trying to crunch
the numbers but once again I didn't get
a solid number of how many people were
in it so I couldn't get an exact but I
think it was around you know 15 to 20
chairs per person on average that's with
many a couple just a few people being
high and most of the people being in the
1 to 10 range so anyway thank you again
everybody and I just can't say anything
but thank you it's it's an honor
it really is it's an honor to entertain
you guys it's an honor to make you laugh
it's an honor to read the comments and
the responses saying that you guys are
just entertained by what I do and that's
that's the greatest feeling in the world
now I would encourage anyone else to do
this so hopefully I'll be playing with
you guys in the future once borderland 2
gets released in mid-september sometime
whenever it is
we'll get this let's play out and ready
to go so thank you again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye